you got to see this guy I don't know
what I said ah I don't remember he's
gonna like how to remember I the old
baby that's what I said
my name is Donald Trump and I'm running
for president
not only did I write a book entitled
crippled America but I also make fun of
crippled Americans and I'll sign either
one you know that awful rich kid in
elementary school who you only talk to
they can see in the best room in the
best video games that's me and I'm
running for president now I switch
political parties more than three times
which is how many times I've switched
wise I used to be respected than
business community but now people would
rather go through months of lawsuits but
to work with me thank God for the
bankruptcy law I can take advantage of
them without having to learn how to run
sustainable companies if I offend you
get out of my country but if you offend
me I'll demand an apology I'm just like
extremely hypocritical in that way money
can't buy you love
that's something I've learned I have
surrounded myself with yes men to the
extent that I no longer know what's good
and bad I don't let myself get weighed
down by what's true thousands of people
celebrated 9/11 in New Jersey and I shot
the Loch Ness monster he's me and a land
deal have I mentioned on racist you hear
about this Jesus guy I feel bad for him
he was always looking to help the poor I
mean it's why I'm not religious unless I
have to be for political campaigns if
you disagree with me shut up but if you
disagree with me shut up yeah that's
right remember how I was wrong about
Obama's birth certificate Fox and
Friends are my only friends the only way
I know how to deal with others opinions
is to remove them from my campaign event
I'm the grandson of an immigrant so I
guess that means my grandfather is a
rapist and a drug dealer and a criminal
I miss my pack knock knock who's there
orange orange who aren't you glad to see
me a lot of people say they don't like
me and that's okay my own father didn't
like me
he gave me a 1 million dollar loan just
to get out of the house
you